you know his big news earlier this year  when Ghostbusters got a total makeover  with four amazing female comedians well  where do you go from there  here's a hint bigger isn't always better  Ghostbusters just got smaller want and a  whole lot cuter forgot about by your  choice  I love the proton pack and the outfit  ghost fighting gear done the iconic car  check and an electrifying amount of the  right attitude yep  I ain't afraid of a ghost who even call  Ghostbusters so who would these mini-me  is called  or I might call myself maybe my god  and also my mom my brother because he's  really strong after a full day of  cuteness the final product speaks for  itself  tunnel wood has been recreating celeb  look-alikes for a while check out their  Kevin Hart Oscars remake they'll be  happy to know he's a huge fan the  funniest thing that I've ever seen this  is actually on our refrigerator in our  house  you